trump's impeachment lawyer taking a
flamethrower to liberal media bias
after a reporter seemed to downplay
house managers
using doctored evidence take a look
it's not okay
the media has to start telling the right
story
in this country the media is trying to
divide this country
you are blood thirsty for ratings and as
such
you're asking questions now that are
already
set up with a fact pattern i can't
believe you would ask me a question
indicating that it's all right just to
doctor a little bit of evidence
oh good gravy danny you got to love
america's left-wing media so we have
bogus news reporting which we've seen
for the last four years or longer
but is this about a blood thirst for
liberals wanting ratings in the media or
is this more of a hatred
for donald trump like i think we work in
cable television we like ratings too
um so i don't know if that's it but we
talk a lot about media and
media bias and um in some time sometimes
i think it can get a little bit
overwrought
but over and over again you see a
situation
like impeachment overall not just about
this blue check mark thing that
vanderbeen was complaining about though
that perfectly fine
but i do think overall with impeachment
you remember what happened last time
impeachment failed never heard about it
again that's right
not during the whole campaign and i have
a feeling that when
i heard i heard somebody say today that
today was really the first day of joe
biden's
presidency because now you had the
impeachment trial finished
and now people would focus on joe biden
however
one of the things i also read today is
that the biden team they plan to keep
president trump front and center because
it helps
you basically allow them to do a lot of
things without getting a lot of media
scrutiny
though that is starting to change and i
think one of the things you'll see is on
school
closures and reopenings like even you
know there's a lot of media coverage on
that from
all all walks of life um i'll leave it
there i know there's a lot of other
people to talk to
i would say we do want to get ratings
but we also do it uh by telling the
truth that's maybe a distinction that we
have with
other networks but i was a former
prosecutor so um
if you don't tell the truth if you lie
or doctor evidence we kind of take that
personally it's not what we do in
prosecution so
to you katie um do you think this is a
big deal that liberals were modifying or
doctoring the evidence in this
impeachment trial
yeah and i think that the attorneys for
president trump were very frustrated and
exposed this bias in the media that we
saw all
last year with the language and
throughout the entire trump
administration quite honestly of the
insightful language the incitement of
going out and attacking cabinet members
attacking trump supporters with you know
violently in the streets that is
something that a number of people called
for you had the
former the vice current vice president
bailing out rioters
after they had done significant damage
by burning down buildings
in minneapolis and everybody kind of
looked around
in the media and shrugged and said well
it's for a cause
and now you have this you know opposite
argument being made by democrats in the
media when it comes to what happened
with on january 6th and so i think that
they're frustrated with the double
standard
they're frustrated with the coverage and
that's why they played over and over
again
words from democrats using very quote
violent language to show the double
standard
and no doubt there's a double standard
and tijuan i think democrats
love to talk about president trump
because they don't have to then talk
about the liberal policies that
americans
don't like but after the second
acquittal now democrats are talking
about potentially donald trump should be
charged and prosecuted
criminally where does this fall on the
unifying america front that joe biden
promised
well i think part of healing sean is
that we
face up to what took place i mean what
took place was grievous in my judgment
i've never seen anything like it i don't
think you have either
the idea that a mob would attack the
congress of the united states and that
the president would be involved that's
just unbelievable but you know in terms
of the the media coverage look i think
we've had three impeachments in the last
20 years
but no matter it's still the ultimate
penalty that the
people of the united states can impose
on a president so it's going to get a
lot of media coverage
and the managers did i think a splendid
job of making
a strong case for conviction
but what we see is that you know they
were i think it
came down to seven republican senators
who are willing to stand up and
face the blow back that came from trump
loyalists across the country
but still that seven is a historic high
in terms of
people voting to convict the president
of their own party we've never seen
anything
to that extent before you had every
democrat
and every independent in the senate vote
for a conviction
mitch mcconnell said you know he thinks
trump was morally
responsible and like he gave a ten
minute speech afterwards
eight of the ten minutes was about
making the case that you know trump was
responsible but he said he just doesn't
like the idea
of convicting someone who's already out
of office but i just want to make this
point the most important thing that came
out of this to me
is the idea that you know with a third
of the country still talking about well
there was fraud in the election
i don't think anybody threw that defense
up in this impeachment i hope that we
can now
bury that lie i don't think impeachment
actually brings america together and 74
million americans
saw the same evidence those senators did
and didn't agree with those votes but to
to you greg uh after the acquittal
president trump has said that the maga
movement is just uh beginning
and there's much more to share in the
months ahead so what do you think is
donald trump
going to run for president a second time
what's his future is it in media
politics what does he do i think that
though says if you want to bury the lie
of election fraud then let's ex let's
investigate it
and make it more transparent if people
can believe
that something was wrong with the
election and not be accused of being
treasonous
your side did it for four years so we're
no no
nobody's gonna bury anything people if
people are concerned
that there's a problem with the election
system the same way
that you feel about the justice system
it was okay for
your side right the democrats the left
to
riot for months over the justice system
but somebody gets ticked off about the
election system and that's treasonous
look it took three
you want to talk about how the media
masters narratives
it took three years to finally slay the
fine people hoax
right and the transcript in full was
online for everybody to see
i know i read it here on the show over a
year ago
and that was the big bang of lies where
all the other lies came from
so the media knows what it's doing the
difference between the right and the
left in terms of media
the left knows that the villains they
designate
are designated by group so like
the five doesn't sit around and make fun
of by abiding
voters right but the left makes fun of
trump voters they talk
they they make fun of law enforcement an
entire swath of
of of people in this world that are
doing their jobs however
we make fun of de blasio we make fun of
cuomo we make fun of
left-wing democrats but we don't make
fun of biden voters
lastly the other trick is withholding
news
until it can't be used against them or
for their point of view the new york
times just admitted
that they were wrong about often or sick
officer sicknick's death they admitted
this though when that information no
longer
could be used in the impeachment he
wasn't killed with a fire extinguisher
we need to find out how the officer died
right
are journalists still interested in that
story or does the story no longer
interest them
good point yeah good point greg